and so welcome to the second of
lightning talks everyone will have six
minutes and it's called lightning talks
because if you go over your six minutes
you'll be struck by lightning so let's
get started first part is I guess my L
block well just in case for the speakers
all right it's being recorded if you're
not happy using this simulator and we
live in a talk before it is that every
talk
we're getting a signal five seconds
before lightning strike so we can
actually end the talk we get a signal a
minute before lightning strikes okay
thank you very much to the organizers
for letting me present them this
lightning talk where I would try to show
you how we used this quantum processor
that we developed here at UC Berkeley in
the group of earphones Siddiqui to it
process store and process ternary
quantum information so three level
systems and then how we would like to
use that to probe the scrambling of
quantum information so first of all
storing information name processing in
three level systems or quantum traits
cue traits it's more than just an extra
level there is some computational
argument to do this Hilbert space gets
larger you get you do this an art very
efficient way and also you get the
higher connectivity so a good network of
cue turrets is more connected than a
network of qubits and especially in this
time of noisy intermediate stage quantum
processors this might give you a nice
benefit if you want to do faster
computation but moreover you get some
new physics if you look at cute rates
versus Q bits it's for instance the
minimal system to study contextual T
which is led to this certified random
number generator recently and the
physics that we are interested in today
is that too cute rates are the minimal
system to implement what is called
scrambling and scrambling is really the
rapid spread of quantum information from
something local to all the degrees of
freedom of the system and it turns out
that this scrambling is really playing a
key role in a connection that has
recently been being made more and more
between quantum cosmology and quantum
information where we're seeing that
physical phenomena such as black holes
the holographic principle and wormholes
really have an analog in quantum
information in such a way that I
once my engineer can now talk to people
who study this fields and understand it
kind of in the language of quantum
information error correction and
entanglement and that's really something
that I'm really excited about and that I
like to study with the systems that we
are working on in particular I'll show
you an experiment that were working on
to study the LIGO information paradox in
the context of scrambling so the devices
that we are working on are this eight
cubed or trans mount chip it's a
superconducting circuits where the the
qubits are nonlinear oscillators in our
case we have eight of them aligned here
is Q 1 2 8 each of them have their
individual readout resonators our chip
as the ability to cope all of these
readout resonators to a single bus such
as we can read them out with a single
channel and I couldn't agree more with
the statements for the experimentalists
two days ago say that it's very
important to quantify all your numbers
and do metrology in our case we do
randomized benchmarking with something
very similar to state-of-the-art single
qubit gates our two qubit gates are now
95 which is probably good enough to do
this experiment but we have ideas how to
improve it so moving on to processing
ternary quantum information or quantum
system is actually a nonlinear
oscillator so we naturally have this
third level it's just usually people
don't really use it so we can excite it
with a different resonant microwave tone
we can detect it in our readout
resonator we've seen the IQ plane of the
microwave field that reflect off of it
we can single shout read out the cute
red state and zero one or two we can
turn on control pulses of variable
length and we can see that we can drive
Rabi oscillations in a single cute red
subspace we can also quantify quantify
how well we can do gates either in the
zero one or the one to transition to
encode
Q traits and what is nice is that we see
is that we don't lose a lot by going to
this one to transition in terms of error
the error is very similar so it really
is a good coherent system that we can
use the process information and then
what we have developed which is new is
2q traits control what we've implemented
is a gate between two q traits and this
is all microwave driven gates where we
turn on a microwave and the effect of
what it does is its rotates a target
qubits in this Q traits in this subspace
depending on the state of the control Q
trade so you
these oscillations that are different
from the control being in one or when
the controls in zero and two and this is
the kind of differential signal that we
use to implement what I would call the
canonical scene out but then for cue
traits so only if the control cube trait
is in one we flip the target and we can
use this to make entanglement between
our two cue traits here we show density
matrix of an EPR state 0 0 + 1 1 + 2 2
with the fidelity it regards to putrid
gates and the fidelity is roughly 95% so
with this system we now like to study
scrambling we have a decomposition of
scrambling unitary to compose out of two
of our two cute red gates and that's
something that we're working towards but
in the final few minutes I want to give
you some intuition of what it would mean
to have scrambling with which you see so
formal definition is that if you have a
two-body system and you see at how
operators get mapped by the unitary you
and you want to check whether you is
scrambling it is scrambling if any
single buddy operator on the first or
the second system gets mapped to a many
buddy operator so that's the spread of
operation of information throughout the
system
and the way that you could see this is
by looking at a process matrix but kind
of flubbed the different legal DiPaola
transfer matrix which looks at when you
input the certain poly operator - which
operators that's at map so here's the
input here's the outputs for local gates
if you would do it on the first system
it would all say local here and then
tangling gates would map some of these
inputs to two-body operators but a
scrambling unitary would map every
single buddy operator to many buddy
operator and that's the ones the process
tomography that we would like to see and
study and the nice thing about our
system is that we could really do this
process tomography because we can do our
measurements very quickly now there's
another way of quantifying scrambling
and that is by doing a circuit that Kris
Munroe actually presented on Tuesday the
short version of it is that you create
two black holes and you entangle them by
a wormhole and you can do this
teleportation protocol where effectively
the wormhole is implemented by
scrambling operation and the protocol
measures the end of time order
correlators between these of the
scrambling operation and
by measuring the success probability and
the teleportation fidelity you get a
feel of how well you're scrambling and
you can compare this how much
decoherence you have in the system so
this is one of the protocols that we
would like to study there is much more
links to high energy physics and other
protocols that we could do with these
key traits so with that I'd like to
thank you and so we have time for one to
two questions depending on life are your
letters symmetrical to 0 1 2 like that
you have big heaps or 0 more robust and
then one in two states oh yeah so our
errors are not symmetric zero is more
robust in terms of energy relaxation and
also actually in phase noise so the
second level is more susceptible to
charge noise so we both have more T 1
errors and more T 2 errors in our second
state
okay let's thank the fire
[Applause]
right is this working good great thanks
this is joint work with Bill Fefferman
chin menurkey and Umar al Zahrani so as
you know of the near term goals of our
field is to establish qualm supremacy
that's you know a practical
demonstration of a clone computation
that's very difficult for classical
computers to reproduce and demonstrating
this kind of requires that you find some
form of computational tasks which is
both feasible in the year term has
strong evidence for hardness from a
complexity theory standpoint and it's
also verifiable at least on near-term
devices so one of the first cracks at
this problem was you know the boson
sampling proposal of Aaronson and
arkhipov and they had this very nice
insight that you can establish quantum
supremacy by making a certain hardness
conjecture the hardness conjecture says
something like it's sharp be hard to
approximate most output probabilities of
some randomly chosen quantum systems and
what made this conjecture so compelling
from the optical standpoint was that for
linear optics it is known to be sharp be
hard to exactly compute these quantities
on average this ends up coming from the
fact that and when your optics output
probabilities are related to permanence
and permanence have a form of
average-case hardness based on a classic
result of Lipton so the only remaining
step to complete the complexity
theoretic proof of supremacy here is to
robusta phi this average case hardness
result and make it make it more robust
to small amounts of error so if we were
to you know plot proposals at a very
high in broad level you know in terms of
the the you know how standard the
complexity assumptions how feasible are
they in the next let's say o of 1 years
I like this phrase now and that how easy
is that the verify in near-term device
you know this had very strong evidence
for hardness and looked like it could be
feasible in the near term so this is
part of what launched the original quest
for experimental supremacy almost a
decade ago ok what what happened since
then is there's been great advances in
the development of say superconducting
qubits and
the other systems and it looks like
we'll be able to implement random
circuits over qubits of a substantial
size in the next row of one years so you
can establish supremacy for these
devices by conjecturing you know it's
hard to compute most output
probabilities of these randomly chosen
cubed circuits but this conjecture has a
gap that was not present in boson
sampling namely that exact average case
hardness is is not known for these
systems and this is just because you
know they aren't as closely related to
permanence and without this form of
average case hardness you know there's
not strong evidence that this is kind of
a hard distribution to reproduce
classically that these generic
interference patterns of qubits cannot
cannot be reproduced classically and
also without this form of average case
hardness you don't have a hard
distribution to test your vais your
device against like if you were trying
to show to me you have a 3sat solver
that solves 3sat in all instances you
know you kind of need a hard
distribution to test it again so you
need to have some evidence that that's
hard so our main result is we fill in
this gap and we show an exact average
case hardness for computing amplitudes
of random circuits over qubits and you
know justice and boson sampling in order
to you know complete the proof of
supremacy you would still need to
robusta Phi it so if you were you know
to plot random circuit sampling on this
high-level plot you know they say prior
to our working of the complexity
assumptions were maybe not as strongly
support than this boson sampling but it
was kind of designed with with
feasibility in mind and our work brings
it up to the level of boson sampling in
terms of our strength of evidence of
belief in these complexity conjectures
possibly even plus epsilon and I say
this because they're also known to have
a property known as anti concentration
which is conjecture for boson sampling
and there's great numerical evidence for
it but but not not yellow proof we also
question to what extent you know it's
actually you know to what extent is
possible to Vera
by these random circuit sampling tests
so some of the leading candidates for
verifying these near-term systems are
called cross-entropy
and heavy output generation and they all
perform some they all take a few samples
from the device and perform some
statistical tests on those samples and
accept if it's sufficiently close to the
ideal so clearly scoring well on these
tests --is is necessary to be doing the
right thing but it's natural to ask you
know is this sufficient as well like is
it also sufficient to verify supremacy
through these these Sharpie hardness
arguments I mentioned before and one
thing that we know this is that actually
if you believe in certain noise models
you might be able to believe these
actually do connect to these to these to
these sharp be hardness result so in
particular we feel that for
cross-entropy if you score very well on
cross-entropy
and you believe the entropy of your
device is higher than it would have been
in the ideal system then your output
distribution is actually close to the
ideal and the certify supremacy in this
way and this assumption could make sense
if you believe in certain types of noise
like say depolarizing noise if you
believe in other types of noise models
it might not make sense so I think that
this could give you a potential way to
to believe in verification of this the
strong measure of complexity and the
near term we also give a sort of optimal
verification test which verifies both
cross-entropy and Hogg at which I don't
have time to discuss so yeah so in short
depending on how you believe in these
assumptions you know you might actually
believe RCS could be verifiable and I'll
just conclude by saying you know there's
many other things you could do here
you know as Scott described this heavy
output generation scheme allows you to
make stronger assumptions and get easier
verification and I'm about to be struck
by lightning so and but there other
things one can do thanks
[Applause]
there's no given and entropy inequality
it has to be greater than oh yeah they
dip it could be greater than or epsilon
less what would still work yeah this is
just from Pensacola equality it says
very very simple put all this in lines
you said if the cross entropy is that
have set on close to the correct yes
yeah yeah polynomial closest is plenty
in fact there there actually should be
quite there should be exponential
convergence and estimating the cross
entropy from samples because in terms of
mean the ideal one right yeah suppose
that I sample Delta closing that one two
idea does that imply that the cost that
will be used
oh I believe so yeah I believe so yeah
this might be some event or something
yeah I'm sorry
in this case the fact that the ideal
distribution has this
is no paper from uniform that you
because you
okay but entropy content your log menu
changes assistance yeah because it's
this thing is already kind of uniform
ish that it's yeah you're kind of
staying in the high entropy area even if
you change it below okay
[Applause]
and I think you were too generous to hog
when you said verifiability is great I
mean it's no thanks to the end time oh
sure it's actually so so does every seat
yeah right yeah right so that we know
and other than
my next talk is Oh everyone I'm captain
Hong and I'm a grad student in
University of Michigan and right now I'm
a research intern at a leading Contin
lab and this is the joint work with my
colleagues Michael Newman and Mario Sega
D who I didn't see any way so the
problem we are looking at is strong
quantum simulation which is using
classical computational power to
simulate or more specifically given poly
sized quantum circuits II and output
string X we want to classically compute
the amplitude on this X component and
this is in contrast to weak simulation
which is more close to supremacy where
we want to sample from the distribution
given by the circuit acting on the audio
stream and it is not hard to see that
strong stimulation is sharpy hard and at
least if you want to do it exactly but
sharpy heart doesn't tell us too much
information about how exactly hard this
problem is and to prove such a lower
bound result one can start from some
complexity assumptions we can so there's
a full hierarchy of assumptions we can
make and results we can get for starters
if we have no assumptions then prevent
anything meaningful would lead to char P
not equal to P and on the other extreme
if we assume that there is a lower bound
then there is a lower bound we are not
proving anything really meaningful but
for some people very paranoid or think
that pH would collapse one day or just
tomorrow these things might not be very
attractive to you so so here is our
result we're saying that here are these
prominent most widely used classical
strong simulation methods they are so
naive and here we called monotone for
for reasons we'll explain later such
that for this type for this regime of
straw simulation method we can prove
unconditional explicit lower bound
unconditional meaning that there is no
complexly assumption needed and explicit
means there's no constant factor and
there is no asymptotics so what is a
monotone method a monotone method so
there are these two points the first one
is it treats the column circuit as a
tensor network more specifically each
gate or each state is just a vector or
matrix or even fancier higher rank
tensor and it only involves addition and
multiplication nonzero entries of the
tensors so here's a very simple example
for the circuit presented on the left
for a monotone methods perspective it
just looks like this what the nonzero
entries are doesn't matter it will just
perform addition and multiplication on
these entries okay so our main theorem
is saying that there is a reasonably
sized circuit with linear width and poly
depth such that such a circuit cannot be
simulated efficiently by any monotone
method and the proof sketch is that so
in order to do this strong simulation
using monotone method we are
disregarding what the properties these
gates can have for example if they are
from clifford group then we can just use
Casas neo to simulate them pretty
efficiently so here we are actually
doing something much stronger we are
trying to use a monotone arithmetic
circuit to compute a multi linear
polynomial and that polynomial could as
well be permanent we constructed a kind
of artificial circuit which can have the
potential of computing permanent using
monotone arithmetic circuit and like 30
years ago it's already proven this is
not possible unless the circuit is of
exponential size okay so why is this
useful the first reason is obviously
most of the widely used strong
simulation techniques provided by
proposed by many former results and even
competition
I mean industrial packages is follows in
this regime for example Schroedinger and
Markov she is just are two ways of
contracting tensor Network and fancier
we can use Feynman path integral or even
Aronson and challenge technique of
making use of savages theory so it's a
yeah and it also provides us an very
interesting by-product which is the
monotone arithmetic circuit computing
permanent in time n square times 2 to
the N which is not known before so naive
algorithm would take n factorial and
sava theorem would bring it down to a 4
to the N but to the N is not done before
this almost matches this is art in a
monotone method of course this is just a
worst-case lower bound we believe that
average-case complexity is provable but
we haven't done it yet so our main
take-home message here is this if we
want to push the classical simulation
ability further ahead then one needs to
focus on not monotone approaches there
are slightly in monotone approaches such
as stazon type fast matrix
multiplication which gives you a
polynomial advantage where there are not
very non monotone ones based on Cosmin
and neo theorem basically saying if it's
not far from a Clifford circuit then we
can still do it efficiently but it's
just a very completely different
approach
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd like to find what is exactly a
monoculture is it a circuit that only
can do anybody populations on the input
and so the pencil or what is exactly the
definition yeah monitor kid mother
arithmetic their kid is a circuit where
the gates are only addition and
multiplication you cannot do a
subtraction or division can you prove
time-space trade-offs like could you
show you know may hope to show that like
we got the optimal trade-off or or the B
didn't Canada that's a very good point
here we're only proving the total time
we didn't consider parallel time for
example yep but I think it's safe to say
that under this regime you cannot do up
to 100 cubic I'm just interested in
approximate so yeah that's another very
good point so there are these things we
need to explore to try to further push
the boundary because but but right now
there is no way of making use of
truncating error to make it more
efficient let's
[Applause]
oh sorry
there's a
okay all right all right hello everyone
I'm da waiting currently a PhD student
at Stanford and also doing your
internship I'll be Bob at the summer and
this is gonna be a talk about noisy
feedback and lost unlimited private
communication some work don't live
psychic ooh ha Arizona okay so the thing
is that many cryptographic protocols
involve the use of a public side channel
for example in BB 84 Bob and Alice are
using a public side channel talk about
which bases I measure in which basis did
I prepare in and therefore this seems to
be have key part of lot of these a lot
of these protocols and he's the public
side channel so the eavesdropper can
also listen and onto this onto this side
channel the thing is that this side
channel is assumed to be perfectly
noiseless to all parties
so all parties have access to your side
channel and it's perfectly noiseless is
usually assumed for simplicity you can
also argue that off there is arms and
noise in that side channel you can use
error correction to get rid of the noise
but what we ask in this paper in our
project is to say is this actually okay
in all circumstances so one thing we
could ask is for example in the
continuous variable case we go to a
continuous variable case your public
side channel becomes a continuous
classical classical continuous variable
classical channel we basically can send
real numbers with zero noise to each
parties this is known in classical
information theory to have infinite
capacity even if you have a power
constraint input constraint onto your
inputs a power constraints your inputs
so and this is the non zero case where
you have infinite capacity is completely
different or the perfect perfectly zero
case it's completely different from the
non zero error case so this kind of goes
against the argument we had earlier
about error correction bringing the
error down can be an error down but
never go to zero and these two cases can
be completely different so we will be
asking our paper is okay this could take
the usual setting for private
communication but let's add a little bit
of noise so this is the following this
is the following setup so Alice has some
quantum Channel a fee and she sends it
over some large number of uses of con
a quantum state fee and she's used she
sends it over some large number of times
of quantum Channel and then you can also
eavesdrop on this quantum channel and in
Bob can also send classical information
back through this feedback loop and Eve
has access to this feedback
communication but on one of the on the
initial round of communication Eve gets
a little bit of noise on that feedback
so if you take out this part this
becomes the usual way of looking at
private feedback assisted private
communication so we're saying okay let's
take a look at this slightly altered
model and let's see what happens what
thing changes so what we showed is that
for the case where the pure loss channel
which is a quantum analog of the
additive white Gaussian awgn channel for
this case if you look at the
conventional model what is this noise
noises feedback throughout we have upper
bound of capacity of negative log 1
minus ada we're ada is the
transmissivity or basically the lost in
that channel the thing about this
capacity is that it's lost limited so
usually when you look up capacity
expressions for continuous variable
channels you have a power constraint on
your input you can't send any input and
then your capacity then becomes a
function of that constraint but in this
case even if you do not have a
constraint on your input you have some
finite upper bound on your capacity and
we call that loss limited so this is
actually a very pessimistic pessimistic
result because it says that qkd you
can't have very high capacities even if
you have a lot even if you have use a
lot of power on your communication so in
our model we add a little bit of noise
to Eve what we get is some new rate one
this this expression the only thing that
you notice is that there's a NS and this
is an input input power constraint and
when you take NS to infinity we're just
saying that you have no input power
constraint this becomes infinite so this
becomes goes from loss limit it to loss
unlimited and that is a big difference
and that is all achieved by adding just
a little bit of noise to Eve's copy of
the feedback on this one round of this
protocol so it went bit fast but the
main message is following if you have
some CV continuous variable crypto bra
cryptographic for
the side channel is some noises
classical TV channel if you add a little
bit of noise on one round you get a
completely different rate of
communication achievable on that channel
and this shows a sensitive dependence on
your communication model so basically a
lot of the treatments theoretical
treatments of cv q KD or private
communication our main message is to say
that you'd be more careful
you can't just naively assume this
public side channels noises and that is
it thank you you didn't have any noise
from Bob to Alice yes yes that is that
is correct
doing it in these noiseless channels
there's already results that even
without a quantum commentary we even
have found a clone Denikin turkey yes
true okay so this is more than say the
song so in the classical setting you can
generate key through a noiseless channel
with feedback right and that no feedback
where there's noise and there's no
feedback nothing else yes true that's
true
I'm not saying quantum Channel is a key
component of this analysis this also
induces a classical result as well yes
there is
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Connect yourself
okay next is Scott Aaronson okay
so so I want to tell you about Shannon
tomography which the paper I wrote
that's gonna be in stock a couple weeks
from now and then some a new work with a
guy Roth which is not out yet okay so so
what were those the problem that I
called a shadow tomography
so what it says is you have there's some
unknown mixed a row okay let's say it's
a d-dimensional and you can get some
copies of row okay so you have access in
your lab to rows okay okay now you know
ordinary tomography would say just learn
the density matrix of row you know
approximately by measuring these copies
and we know that that requires something
like these squared copies in fact you
know there were break some breakthroughs
a couple years ago so it was finally
established that
what are these squared copies of row are
necessary and sufficient for a fertile
ography okay but now let's suppose that
we have a more limited bill so you know
a list of two outcome measurements you
want up to bf so you say they're POV m/s
right and your goal is just for each eye
you would like to know the approximate
value
you of Tracy I Rev alright so for each
of these measurements what's
approximately the probability that it
accepts rental okay
well then a couple of years ago I posed
the question how many copies of roe are
needed to do this okay you know let's
let's ignore for for now computation
cost okay well clearly you know d
squared copies are sufficient because
you can just do phone tomography at a
different extreme of parameters
something like M copies of row well also
clearly suffice because I could just
apply each VI to separate copies of row
okay but for various questions and
quantum money quantum copy protection it
was relevant to know well could you do
this using a number of copies of road
which is poly logarithmic in both T and
n okay so even you know to learn an
exponentially large state on
exponentially many different to outcome
measurements could we do that using and
Lee polynomial in many copies of the
state okay so I conjectured that this
was you know probably not possible I
could not rule it out and now you know
why I couldn't roll it out because it's
possible okay and so well this was in
the I'm sorry there's Gil Ian's talk
yesterday okay but so I gave a an
algorithm that does it with like this
number of copies of row where as the
only lower bound that I know is a is
this which holds even in the classical
case okay so you know an incident this
this implies for example that you know
any scheme for quantum money with a
small key or any scheme for quantum
copy-protected software will require
computational assumptions it cannot have
been firm a
theoretic security hey this this has
various other implications ok now you're
a guy I gave a talk about this
and a guy brought blah was in the
audience and he said well this you know
you know then ok so so you're gonna to
prove this you know you have to sort of
measure your copies of row very very
carefully to avoid damaging them too
much right I won't have time to go into
you know how the protocol works involved
you know sort of combining two ideas one
is going you know post selected learning
of quantum states and the other is
called the quantum or bound and this is
like a type of sort of gentle
measurement that doesn't disturb States
by too much right which is clearly
needed here and so so then the guy said
well this whole gentle measurement this
sounds a lot like differential privacy
okay what is what is that right well
this is how many notes like a little
more a minute all right differential
privacy is a subject where you look at
algorithms that are query and database
within entries and you impose the
requirement that you know the algorithm
does not reveal too much about any the
date of any individual user so say if we
have two databases X and X prime to
differ and only a single entry then we
say the probability that you know the
output is y under database X has to be
like at most 1 plus epsilon times the
probability that the output is y on
their database the next prime okay and
the way that you achieve this tends to
be things like you know add some random
noise to the result of the clarity
before you return it which you know
interestingly is the same kind of thing
that you do to get gentle measurements
and quantum mechanics right you just
sort of add some Gaussian noise to your
you know answer you can avoid damaging
your state by too much ok so so yeah I
think ok with this
probably just you know you can connect
anything to anything else all right well
I'm story short there is a connection
here we can prove it it goes in both
directions and we can use this
connection to improve the shadow
tomography I believe we can get this
forward down to it too by taking the
results from differential privacy and
boarding them into the setting of gentle
measurements yeah do you think that the
quantum techniques can give back
something to differential planets that
would be awesome we thought about that
we don't have an example without that
that would be awesome if we could do
that and your questions
okay
okay next talk is I will have disbanded
I'm happy now and this ongoing joint
work with both women who is here in the
audience Jim Garrison and Alex Akash
Cove at tricks and UMD so the motivation
is that a lot of work in physics is
actually classification such as like we
have phases of matter where people are
interested in knowing whether ground
states are ordered or disorder and
people are interested in generally in a
long time behavior of States as to
whether States thermalize or not and
whether there are other exotic forms of
a god is like non-university breaking
like localization of pre-colonization
and whether this topological order and
like whether a state is topological or
not and if it's not and what's the
relevant symmetry class or applies since
I'm here at Simons
I'm talking about complexity theory so
complexity theory is a natural
classification of problems into easy or
hard and what we want to do is see
whether this kind of classification can
be useful in physics too and one
question that we ask us whether tools
study in the context of quantum
computation supremacy can be applied to
physics but not necessarily the same
goal in mind that so we are not
necessarily trying to falsify the
extended church-turing hypothesis
so now go into some brief background
about predicting entangled pair states
which are also known as EPS so these are
analogs of matrix work states in two
dimensions and like matrix mark states
they're good on ZJ for ground states
that satisfy a a loss and like how when
caveat is that shall be hard to contract
in general and so the key idea behind
that proof is that peps can represent
output states of both selected corn
circuits
so in that figure here's a general
quantum circuit which acts on an input
state and some an sylla's in registers X
and W and in this register you condition
you measure and condition on the output
being a particular string that you want
and this data appearing in this register
Zed is what I call a output straight off
a postulate at home circuit so now this
result by Xu Canada's can be
reinterpreted in the modern times in the
following sense that pep sampling is
hard
so what's pep sampling it's the problem
so here's a black box that given a
description of a pet state examples from
that state in Saylor computational basis
now what we can show like essentially
what shook and others showed is that
with with this box you can solve pipi
problems in polynomial time if you make
Paula many many ways
so I can like earn money from that or
more formally PPS and be PPT or pips so
this implies that if one could feasibly
build a pep sampler then P P equals P P
P which is very unlikely and this result
state Foley can give you an a result for
hardness of approximate sampling
so now since we want to make the
connection to physics we use this result
by Paris Garcia and others which shows
that any pep state is arbitrarily close
to the unique ground state of a
spatially local Hamiltonian so as a
corollary we can obtain something like
this
that there is a class of local
Hamiltonians for which it's not possible
to approximately sample from the ground
state and even quantumly unless P P
equals P P P because the nowhere here
did I assume that the Oracle was
classical or anything
so yeah the the preceding reason is why
there is not a proposal for corn
computation supremacy because we don't
have a quorum sampler and hardness
assault applies even corn mechanically
we also get some robustness to total
variation distance errors and so as of
now this result just applies to print
Hamiltonians of a very specific class of
states their output states of for
selected corn circuits so one problem is
whether we can make this more natural in
the sense of where they can give more
restricted hamiltonians for which the
harnesses all still applies also this
result does not assume anything about
the gap and it can be arbitrarily small
in general and any improvement on this
seems unlikely unless these two classes
are equal here P to the QM a log is when
you have access to a QM a Oracle and you
can call it log ultimately many times
this work and preceding work by men is
show that P to the QM a log is actually
in P P
and one other question is whether
whether we can use some sort of
classification for other classifications
we have more standard means such as the
problem of computing ground state
energies of hamiltonians so that's more
like that's relating with the QA and QC
MA literature and yeah once we have that
we can ask the question like which
states are classically easy
or quantum easy and quantum hard and
whether there are phase transitions
[Applause]
[Music]
which slide was but you were saying that
there's a theorem that says that the
given the patch says input it's hard to
sample from the distribution and then
you use that to deduce the theorem that
says a given the local Hamiltonian as
invoices or juice yes
so that uses yeah you can construct a a
local Hamiltonian that's apparent
Hamiltonian of the pipe straight
good
any other questions
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay next speaker is sacred complexity
lower bounds for myself okay so first
off why are we even looking and
interested in circuit complexity well it
is well known that in a classical
computation lower bounds on circuit
complexity are very hard to find and
they are also a very good metric of how
complicated calculation is and also in
the quantum setting we have a lot of
different kind of domains where we are
interested in finding such lower bounds
the first first two that I can think of
in the QP CP conjecture the quantum
kispa conjecture and also in the NLDS
conjecture which are both very
interested in showing that some states
are non-trivial when triviality is
quality of a quantum states it just is
the quantum state can i generate the
conscious state with constant depth
circuit and we are interested in ruling
out some states and showing that there
are complex in this sense and also in
multiple are tight entanglement we are
interested in finding such lower bounds
so let's look at the kind of methods
that we have two days that are known to
show these kind of lower bounds so the
first method that I can think of okay is
what I would call the correlations
methods so what does it mean well if you
look so first the easiest example you
can see
is if you have a cap state okay and you
want to show that this state is we
cannot generate this state with a
constant depth secret then you can just
look at two different qubits okay and
look at the light cones and you can just
say that if you assume by contradiction
that you can generate cut plus using a
constant depth set with you for you can
see that the light concern of every if
you look at the computation going this
way and here you to bits okay and here
the input qubits then you can see that
the light cone of any given qubit here
is going to touch a constant number of
qubits on the input layer and therefore
if I look at it I can also always find
another qubit here that whose the light
cone is going to be completely
disconnected from this one and and this
in this situation we are we expect those
two qubits to be a completely
uncorrelated but they are obviously
correlated and this is this is the
contradiction and the same type of
argument is used is actually the most
general generalization of this kind of
argument is liberals and Leibowitz and
bounds which also gives a logarithmic
lower bound for self weights which are
generated of other states for generating
states services that come from a
maintenance at a gapped and recently
more recently L darlin room have proved
used
same type of argument to show is to show
a generalized version of the nnts
conjecture and so this is the first
method and we have another method is
which is just looking at a state and
saying that okay if this state is part
of quantum about collecting code and if
the distance is L then obviously any two
state orthogonal states inside this gun
state are going to be to agree on
residences metrics on less than L cubed
and you can use this fact in order to
achieve the same kind of local bounds
but I will I don't have time to show it
now so what is known for home article
codes so for the metrical codes we have
a very beautiful and geometrical proof
of of broth okay who showed that in some
interesting regime which is which I
would call the junk geometrical regime
which means if I look only if I reduce
myself to look at only at secrets that
are geometrically local in the grid of
of how topological a code so for example
if you have a total code that we have
the grid of the total code yes and now
we can ask whether I can build the
ground state of this of this code using
only geometrically local gates which are
not only yes not only locally in terms o
of qubit if we get act upon but also in
terms of the geometry of of the gates we
want the gates to act on qubits that are
close close by in the grid matrix and in
this case bradley showed that we have a
lower bound okay
[Music]
of square root of n ok so we need Amiga
of square root of n depth or to generate
this kind of this kind of topological
ground state and the basic idea ok so I
will just state how easy to state our
results very quickly yes so so my result
is like this we prove that if we are
looking at if you are looking at a
generating the ground state of the
spherical code which is the same as
toric code we do it but we don't use
topology to preserve the Oh militia
groups are just vanishing so we can't
use the same type of arguments that we
used in order to prove that states
inside the quantum code general roca
native code are difficult to generate
here we don't have this this power but
we can still prove the same kind of
lower bound which what we do prove is
that in this case of a non-jew
non-geometric a local state submits
sorry we get a lower bound off of log N
and in the case of more general surfaces
don't need to look at Lydian then we can
in Association for another protocol
conditions that we are not going to
speak about now we get double
logarithmic bound for for generating
these states
[Applause]
do you expect the log to be tight origin
or the spoon this way actually actually
it is tight because if you look at
surfaces that are not behaving totally
in an oak lesion way if you look at
something that is more like a hyperbolic
plane then then this logarithm is you
can do better than this logarithm this
is like tight also estate
Russians
[Applause]
[Music]